i do not my person i'm not teaching
quran but i may teach the younger kids
[Arabic recitation]
my own idea is
i don't students to read to write
quran the the thing is i don't want them
to be you know to miss the paper
or misplace it or something this is the
only concern for me
if but if it helps you do it
okay
and inshallah if
maybe if it's helped him
[Silence]
yes if it helps you do it and everybody
has a different strategy yes i
don't i don't writing it but
there's okay so i thought you weren't
writing okay okay
okay you are giving an example then it's
not for you
okay
there's other strategies okay
i'm not teaching quran so you know like
okay so what we are the way that you
know i used to teach quran is
they need to be able to recognize the
surah they need to be able to recognize
the words they need to to know exactly
excellent of course this is the main
idea
every you know most of the people
who knows me you know like
i don't
i i encourage memorizing the quran but
what's more important for me is to
understand the quran
okay
yes
actually that makes me really happy
you're
excellent
and i would just to add to what
teacher
as you said everyone has different
strategies and different learning style
right so
what i encourage everyone is if at any
point you feel like
you need a different strategy or you
don't understand or something doesn't
make sense
feel free and brave like
what you just did and talk to the
teacher any teacher okay islamic studies
if you feel you can get this just
go and talk to the teacher and tell him
i really can get this and then he will
change the style or he will discuss with
you what you need to do and sorry but
that was great
from the parents
from the ladies
any questions
yes
at the end of the day i would to
can you come here
thank you
this is she's you're from yemen right
now foreign
at the end of the day i want to
present that
i know
a loss
99 names
so
can you give us five minutes and
then we'll do this
before we finish yeah
okay
that okay and you're maybe if
there's others they will know it can
they you know share can they come
with you and do it with you
okay
any suggestion any ideas yes
i just want to give you a chance maybe
to present
what items or things
that you might want
not necessarily us as we you know as a
board you have unlimited support
whatever you want but maybe if you want
to to list items or things that the
school needs maybe the parents can help
so some resources that the school might
need you want to convey to the parents
so if they want to help they can help
i think you know the first thing
that we need is we need volunteer right
we also would as i said inshallah
to encourage your kids to bring their
materials and belongings before they
come to the sunday school
remind them to bring their notebook
their
you know pencils every time they
come you know
i asked the students where's your paper
oh teacher i forgot it or teacher you're
i don't know maybe i take it maybe
i forget it
so
i think this is really essential so help
us in that and inshallah ta'ala some
of the parents they ask you know like
that they want to help insha'allah in
the future if we need papers
notebooks maybe even
construction papers crayons anything
you know for the school insha'allah
i would be asking the parents
let me just know that you are willing to
help us and support us
okay
[Silence]
any suggestion
any ideas
yes
my name is mustafa yes
my father's name
i'm originally from bangladesh yes so i
am i'm just making a general comment i'm
not sure if it is a suggestion
my
so i have two boys
[Silence]
yes and generally my goal
my
boys is
my goal about the religious and islamic
education what i object throughout my
life is that
many times we don't understand what we
read
my boys try to memorize quran and surah
and at some time he will forget
because as sharp as they think that or
you know i can memorize this of my life
so
i
so generally strategy that if they i'd
rather they learn free what what does it
mean
and a lot of time is is easy to say but
you know
interpreting arabic and islamic and
history these are these are very complex
stars
but you know end of the year if they
understand key word from quran what does
it mean
they might carry the rest of their life
rather than memorizing 20 surah and then
basically after five years if they have
tried to recite
they will forget and they don't know
what they are doing
i'm not
i'm not stressing that you know
memorizing anything bad
this is important you know it's
important they will keep memorizing but
my afraid is that you know i memorized i
didn't understand anything
i still memorized you know i don't know
anything and then a lot of time
i hear people interpret and talk
because they don't know the word so you
know anyway or if they can write too
hard in a year
you know if they really know that they
can write another 10. something like
that
that's my brother can i answer sister
i'm sorry because it's my job
can
[Silence]
okay the way i teach it is i i do it
word by word and then i give word by
word translation
then i give the general meaning of the
ayah that he recites or teaches and then
if there is a reason the reason of
revealing the ayah at the time
[Silence]
foreign
so
and then after i'm giving the
general meaning of the verse i repeat
the verse five times according to
what satan
[Silence]
and i also focus on the degree and
the the
techniques of reciting
and then i have them decide and i
correct them
you know brother let me tell you from my
own experience just you know what to add
to what you said
subhanallah when i started as a teacher
this is exactly what i would use to face
i used to ask the students open the
quran read surah
ali you know
just open the quran find the surah none
of the students were ap were able to
open the quran and find this world for
me
and subhanallah you know we need to
learn what's their needs because we are
not living as back home if i'm teaching
quran or arabic language back in my
country in syria
or i'm from syria let's say
i'm going to teach it in a different way
and a different approach and a different
method
we are living in america we need to
look at the students needs
and really i found that
there's a generation
they do not understand the quran
because not because of them i feel sorry
for the students it's because of those
who taught them quran
so insha'allah that's why brother
i always believe
that the students need to understand
what they are reading
and this is one of the important thing
even in public school that's why what we
are trying to do is
learn from the system the american
system and try to apply it into our
school into the sunday school
in a way that fits with their needs and
in a way that meets their needs so this
is what we are doing you know brother so
and let's go back to arabic if you look
at the book that's why
gave me this book and that's why we
chose it
is that if you look at the
words and vocabulary maybe 60 to 70
percent of these words mentioned in this
book it's from the quran
and at the beginning on the top of the
page it does have the words at its
meaning
and i believe it's it's a it's a higher
level this but inshallah ta'ala since i
asked the students and they told me they
really want to understand and read quran
that's why i decided to do to use that
so it's a different you understand your
brother
so inshallah ta'ala we will do our best
but again we need your help
and the parents help
we need really to think more serious
about the new generation
really
and we are facing lots of challenges you
know at the beginning of the
lessons you know
some of the students they are here
and they don't have the desire to and
from their face from the way that they
look at us they don't have the desire to
learn
they maybe they had a bad experience i
don't know
but we need insha and i told them
inshallah we will try to gain back your
trust
and i want them really
to feel the importance of what we are
doing and what they are learning
it's a challenge
some of the students they look at us as
if you know what are you doing
great
and ask them
especially the older kids so we are
trying to get there we have lots of
challenges
is that what we want
so we need really to think seriously
we don't want to lose more generation
enough is enough for me this is what i
feel because you know i'm a mom and
i have a son
so
so please
we are here
to inshallah to educate your kids but i
also want you to be there to help us
with that
banners in that issue
insha'allah
we don't want to take more time oh
there's a question
okay
inshallah since we said that our main
goal of the sunday school is to apply
what we are learning
the sheikh will give us inshallah we
will we will share the food we have a
barbecue but before that oh sorry very
question
[Silence]
you may be
i understand so the time you are talking
about the time
i understand
so you think that time is not you
know it does not it's not
appropriate for you
it's okay
from
yeah from what i heard from some of the
you know from talking with some
parents it seems that the time is good
for them just because the woman's they
have a time to wake up you know like
especially at sunday so they wanted
enough time to wake up prepare for you
know they have certain issues but
inshallah in the future if we hear you
know some of the parents they want
any changes
at that time insha'allah
our goal is to implement and apply what
we are learning
as a community inshallah we will have
lunch together we have a barbie very
much i hope
you will enjoy it
but before we go
insha'allah will give us maybe five
minutes
not lecture but just a
reminder of
i believe everyone needs to remember
this stuff insha'allah we need to apply
it
from adults kids young women's
everyone
let's apply the sunnah let's go back to
sunnah and when we do that insha'allah
it's the time we shall talk for us to
succeed
other than that
[Arabic recitation]
we want to be those people who will do
what they say
do you agree with me
we are
we are enough you know we heard a
lot
we want to see actions
we should to do it insha'allah we
can do it we shall buy allah
so please
[Silence]
and brother heider
and everyone
help us
in the sunday school
i ask allah
put this
put
this
good
thank you everyone for coming to sunday
to this open
house
for sunday school
m
[Silence]
which means
all men
eat the lawful
and good things out of what is in the
earth
and do not
follow the
footsteps
of the shaytan
surely
he is your open
enemy
the first thing
from manners
or adam
for eat
or for food
food
very important
eat
from halal
love this is very important
because
i see
more brothers
brothers and sisters
and parents don't care with his
children
about
halal food
this is very important
and
if you eat
from
halal food
allah will accept your dua
if you not eat
from halal food
allah
not accept your dua
this is very important dear brothers
and sisters
someone he said we are in america yes we
are in america
but also
we have more stores
halal food
has halal food this is very important
here
sometimes
the
everyone knows
when she was a kid
her father
asked her
and bring to her some food
and he said
eat from this food
she asked
she replied to her father
oh father
this food
from halal
or from haram
she was five years
five years
and
her father
replied
if this would not hala
you don't
you will not eat
she said never
why
rabia she said
because she said because
i best
and
hungry
i prefer to i prefer to hungary
with zakumal
zakum this world in arabic language
is a tree
in the
hellfire in january
you will smile
this
this smell
from
500 years
ahead
another thing
[Silence]
oh boy
when you will
eat
say bismillah
is the first thing
and
eat with your right hand
what will
be a munich
then
eat with the front of you
don't go to an
another way
with your
be
if anyone
forget
say bismillah
and he
remember in the middle of the night
in the end
he will say
in the beginning and in the
end
and when you will finish
all praise
to allah
because for he give me this food and
also will give me this
dream
this is dear brothers and sisters is
very important for this allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala says
about this ayah
if you say
eat with bismillah hand
and
with the front of you
the shaytan
will be not eat with you
this is very important
and also
about the
manners in the food
eat together
prophet muhammad
the best food
who
eat together
with more
more ham and more baraka allah
this is very important i see
here
if anyone can go to
they have time very important
dear sisters dear mother
their mothers very important put time
for your family and sit together allah
will be made
in your food
and also you can speak
with fool
this is from sunny because
of
be different with the
jews and
christians because they
because they do not speak
with the
only
age this is very and also the scala they
said this is good for your stomach if
you speak something
with food
and the parents ask his son
what do you do today
what you take and also the model this
also make mercy and love together in the
in the food
this
i don't make more time and also follow
your
your kids about
do this and if you
you can
teach your children also
oh my children
what do you say if you start
all my children oh my baby
are you finished yes what you say
alhamdulillah
this
for allah will be
oh again please dear brothers and
sisters if you have any question you can
follow us in the website
mcc
tusan.org
ncc
to san.org
and also in the facebook
muslim community
center
center thank you
very smart
[Silence]
foreign